moi je pense ça fait grossir mais
j'adore les pâtes bon marché faciles à
cuisiner les pâtes sont à la mode en
cette période de confinement mais
attention kilos en trop en 1970 cette
femme avait la solution pour les manger
sans grossir pour ne pas grossir
vous prenez vos deux doigts vous la
tenez bien verticale en 1987
autre méthode autre style avec le
designer philippe starck la pâte
française celle à la coquille est il
nous présentait sa nouvelle gérante à la
télévision idéal pour garder la ligne
qu'est-ce qui est fonctionnel dans une
pâte l'idée c'est de deux queues qui
mangent une pas c'est quelqu'un qui veut
être un petit qu'un peu qu'ils venaient
pas un as et après ils mangent beaucoup
de pâtes après il dit j'ai grossi alors
on va essayer de lui faire manger plus
d'air que deux parties mais si prendre
du poids ne vous fait pas peur les papes
c'est la vie alors il ya le concours du
plus gros mangeur de spaghettis c'était
à haverskerque dans le nord de la france
en 1994 1 m 86 125 kg un style tout en
puissance
l'enfant du pays fred caudron après un
finish éblouissant il décrochera le
titre mondial
un kilo 882 spaghetti englouti le héros
du jour a bien digéré sa victoire et
pour les plus gourmands
voici la recette des noues le chocolat
de marcel mouloudji en 1974 alors là
sans tarder vous voyez immédiatement
tout sur les pattes à l'abri à bas bruit
évidemment et puis alors la voyez tout
de suite on tourne
alors ça vous fait de merveilleuses
nouilles au chocolat
voilà
[Musique]